bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans l'émission
à 6 ans par les sports le talk est
consacré comme vous le savez à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
il y aura des coups de gueule des
analyses des débats et des duels ses
programmes de l'émission quatre
chroniqueurs sont en plateau aujourd'hui
tels des gladiateurs ils sont prêts à en
découdre dans l'arène présentation de la
tille 78 en musique on commence à droite
cds spartacus du cyclisme yvin wild le
site vélo dans le sang et a été champion
d'europe de cyclisme sur piste masters
c'est vice champion du monde
il aime également les sports extrêmes
gagneriez est avec nous aujourd'hui
bonsoir michael en serial vous allez
bien très bien alors vous avez vu une
émission d'absence une émission
d'absence pour cause professionnelle il
faut bien travailler il faut bien
travailler un petit peu bon on est ravi
de retrouver en tout cas au no 6 et
cuivre on passe au deuxième à gladiator
musique il est l'entraîneur de l'équipe
seniors du club de rugby de plaisir il
est un peu triste aujourd'hui car son
club a été éliminé à des play-offs
contre anthony c'est toujours un plaisir
de recevoir genlis de même ça va pas
trop triste un petit peu triste pour le
bo pour le club mais je tiens à faire
remarquer que contrairement à certaines
de mes amies chroniqueur je me suis pas
échappé d'accord mais quand c'est
sûrement alexandre taillefer qui est là
je les vois ces jeux le rentier en abras
raiders du handball à versailles on
repasse à droite musique
il est le président de l'étoile sportive
de trappes il s'est proposé pour
remettre la coupe d'europe pendant
l'euro vu que michel platini a quelques
ennuis avec la justice mustafa larbaoui
nous fait l'honneur de venir sur ce
plateau
bonsoir mustapha bonsoir alors c'est une
rumeur ceux de remettre la coupe
d'europe l'équipe de france par exemple
le 10 juillet prochain pendant l'euro
ouais c'est qu'une rumeur n'est qu'une
rumeur je le confirme je vous laisse je
confirme une rumeur à petit mot sur
michel catty ce temps j'aurais surtout
parlé des gladiateurs qui sont sur le
plateau parce que là on a mélangé les
catégories quand même j'arrête va dire
mais j'ai vu quelques carrure
impressionnante
d'eau sont pas bien méchants ont été
recensés on termine ce tour de table à
gauche musique
il est nouveau sur ce tome que c'est un
fou de sport us il est d'ailleurs
président des templiers d'elancourt
l'une des meilleures équipes de france
comment vous sentez vous
georges agostino pour cette première
parfaitement bien vous avez par les
missions du tout on verra ça on verra ça
on va passer maintenant donc au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de handball féminin et de
la descente de mon team retenu en
nationale 2 nous allons parler de bmx et
des jo mais tout de suite vous avons
parlé de plaisir le club de rugby de
plaisir coup de projecteur donc sur le
rugby
plaisir sort par la petite porte de la
vie des playoffs de fédérale 3 après
avoir perdu le premier match sur le
terrain d'anthony le dimanche 1er mai 11
à 10 les plaisirs oies ont été éliminés
sur leur terrain ce week-end les
yvelinois se sont inclinés à 22 à 17 au
terme d'un match à suspense devant plus
de 600 spectateurs
on écoute le vice capitaine de l'équipe
quant au match aller on a fait pas mal
d'erreurs
je pense que il ya des moments clés du
match lyon doit marquer un repas en fait
bizarre
individuelles collectives de choix
tactiques anthony c'est une belle équipe
ils ont réussi à exploiter tout ça
moi je pense que sur les deux matches
poterie mérite plus de monter grande
bon je le rappelle plaisir a fini
deuxième de sa poule plaisir était
décent et est en fait de l'année
dernière est ce que c'est une surprise
de voir plaisir se faire éliminer vous
votez oui ou non
genre georges surprise donc
non non c'est bon ou pas pour autant on
va commencer très bon genre on vous
laisse vous expliquer avant d'expliquer
une surprise il faut savoir quand même
que le championnat le championnat donc
c'est des phases de poules
les quatre premiers sont qualifiés pour
les phases finales du championnat de
france et qu'il faut passer les deux
premiers tours en match aller-retour
pour prétendre à monter à l'étagé
supérieur qu'est la fédérale 2 en
l'occurrence on a fini deuxième de poule
un poil de ris orangis finissant 2e le
calendrier n'est plus le mot n'est pas
le même forcément
et on a pris anthony où je savais
pertinemment qu anthony ce serait très
dur à mesure c'est une équipe qui nous
ressemble qui est très proche de nous
les résultats sont là ils ont gagné il
n'y a absolument rien à dire sur leur
victoire
on aurait pu très bien gagner et avait
rien à dire non plus deux équipes très
proches et un match de rugby c'est amal
jour d'hui c'est comme dans tous les
sports il faut un perdant un point il
faut un vainqueur
cette fois-ci c'est nous qui avons perdu
après tout remettre en question
le monte c'est pas évident c'est pas
évident notamment parce que il ya ces 15
cp au foie ou après enfin ces phases
finales où nous rencontrons les foules
les grosses équipes se rencontrent quoi
donc
logique il n'y a pas de logique d'un
dans le sport on n'a pas fait exprès de
perdre
on était tous là pour organiser c'est la
logique du sport par contre une équipe
qui domine finalement avec je ris
orangis sa poule et qui se fait éliminer
c'est une surprise selon alors je vais
je les fais moi je l'exprimé comme ça
c'est pas une surprise mais en même
temps c'est le fait qu'on dise que c'est
une surprise ça prouve bien qu'on
attendait quand même autre chose comme
résultat donc ce n'est pas une surprise
qu'à un moment donné il ya une logique
ça vient d'être appelé à une logique et
une logique dans le sport surtout quand
c'est que sur un championnat ça dieu il
ya des allers retours il ya quand même
plutôt que d'en plutôt que de ce qu'on
voit dans une coupe ou lorsque ça se
joue sur un match on peut avoir des
surprises avant un moment donné sur un
championnat c'est un petit peu différent
mais ce que j'aime c'est qu'on puisse
dire justement de plaisir c'est une
surprise
auquel cas on aurait pu avoir le même
tout à fait l' inverse
effectivement anthony a fait ce qu'il
fallait mais plaisir ne démérite pas
c'était l'an dernier en l2 en fédérale 2
voilà moi j'ai presque aller mittal ce
qui n'aurait pas été des surprises non
plus c'est que souvent quand on descend
de deux au final mans c'est déjà de
pouvoir se maintenir sur la marche sur
le podium
on a vu d'autres équipes tombé du haut
niveau est tombé vraiment très bas parce
que c'est à la fois un problème
d'organisation interne et en même temps
un problème de voile à un problème de
coaching
après là pour le coup ils finissent sur
le podium le fait même de se poser la
question de savoir si c'était une
surprise et déjà la bonne surprise de
l'année
mais après j'ai après après c'est à
notre décharge quand même c'est que
notre poule était peut-être un petit peu
trop facile entre guillemets y avait pas
assez assez d'équipés est passée la
diversité voilà à passer l'équipe d'un
bon niveau et notamment la préparation
pour la phase finale où le calendrier 25
ans et qui veut ça les trois derniers
matches avant les matches de phase
finale on a joué les trois derniers de
la poule
donc ça ne va pas du tout favorisé
préparer vraiment les phases finales
parce que l'opposition on a mis à chaque
fois didier raoult dans le confort
peut-être cette poudre dans le confort
il est difficile de maintenir un goût
un bon niveau lorsqu'on n'a pas
l'adversité en face qui répond et ça
s'est passé parce mob et les autres
clubs c'est pas ça c'est le résultat qui
est là c'est voilà les trois derniers de
poule on joue les trois derniers de
poule les trois derniers matches de
phase finale de phase aller fait de
façon retour pardon de phase de
qualification est forcément après pour
la préparation des matches d'un bon
niveau
ben c'est pas c'est pas la meilleure à
la meilleure préparation qu'on puisse se
faire et vous auriez préféré peut-être
aller dans la poule d'anthony du coup
est dans la poule 1 dans la poule 1 tony
ce qui est certain c'est que avait une
poule avec un petit peu plus d' équipe
au moins au moins les cinq six premières
équipes qui étaient qui était un un
mouchoir de poche qui rivalisaient nous
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
mise à paris c'est nous on s'est battu
pour la première place mais après
derrière
de mémoire je sentais le néant le
troisième il se lie 10 soit 20 points
que le troisième c'est marcq en baroeul
ils sont à 20 points donc il y avait un
fossé alors que dans l'autre poule
effectivement les six premières équipes
au moins les six premières équipes
étaient quand même un petit peu plus
serré et donc plus de compétition à de
préparation c'est le syndrome s'est
arraché ses membres du pge observable le
plg a fait rare parce que le championnat
était fun et qui se retrouvent en coupe
d'europe et j'ai grosse équipe et c'est
souvent compliqué pour aller dans son
sens dans votre sens moi ce que je
trouve un petit peu dommage avec le
rugby c'est justement ces finales c'est
phase de playoffs c'est à dire qu on
joue ce qu'il faut à la fin non c'est
que on joue toute la saison pour pour
aller chercher une place dans le
classement dans le classement où tout le
monde se rencontre et au final on peut
finir premier de sa poule et derrière ne
pas ne pas monter de ne pas monter et je
trouve ça un peu dommage ça veut dire
que l'on joue toute l'année ça sert à
rien et puis derrière
eh ben on va jouer la coupe il faut se
qualifier quand même tu joues le
samarien c'est sa c5 c'est un mélange de
championne elle des gens de la haye de
coupe parce qu'après il ya des matches
couperets riche en matches aller retour
je suis inquiet locaux
si je me fais partie - at-c c'est la
génération où le rugby ce cd phases
finales c'est que même regard des années
regardez en top 14 est d'accord at on
fait attention et déjà celui qui l a
beaucoup qui prêche pour que le premier
comme la pro d2 la pro d2 le premier à
l'issue du championnat
le premier il est un champion de france
mais aujourd'hui c'est michal lève cette
culture les phases finales
fort justement vous avez le même
problème finalement boudé on est en
phase finale
et quand je dis qu'il ya pas de surprise
ces crampes et offrent généralement on
retrouve les meilleurs pubs retenus
étaient trois en examen troisième vous
étiez deuxième bon voilà c'était pas une
surprise que l'avant-dernier vous battez
les play-offs
par définition il n'y a pas de surprise
puisqu'on retrouve les meilleurs clubs
français
enfin français du mois de procès le
mixte championnat où la ja - pas de
surprise normalement le suc a vraiment
bien bossé toute l'année sauf que c'est
ce mixte coupe championnat qui fait qu'à
la fin il ya une mutation alors que en
finissons deuxièmes de votre championnat
feuilles de savannah vous auriez pu être
satisfait de la saison il le sait ce que
ça veut dire je le sais ils ne savent à
l'autre est parti puis moins angoissé
coûter encore une fois même moi tu m'as
l'air les phases finales
ça va bouger plus bas rhin la saison
n'est plus la même juste une petite
parenthèse comme ceux notre équipe
réserve
elle est qualifiée est encore qualifié
elles ont ils ont battu vaillamment
anthony donc il ya un bon vivre la même
équipe anthony qui eux avaient pour le
coup elle finit 1er poule avec 10 points
d'avancé
nous on est fier que le quatrième
plaisir dernier notre notre réserve
notre réserve a battu anthony très à
l'aise et jouera donc les seizièmes de
finale dimanche contre et jaune c'est
pour ça qu'il faut voir son plus
valeureux parce qu'ils font la coupe de
france depuis le début
le chant des oiseaux saison et ils
finissent premiers quand c'est le psg en
coupe de france et en championnat ils
arrivent ils arrivent bateau sans même
sortir arrive en coupe de france
une fois que j'avais fait on fait tous
les matchs tous les âges depuis le
départ du premier huitième tour je parle
du premier quitte rome le championnat
elle vous et 41 mustapha vous jettez
vous vous écartez c'est parce que les
prochaines questions est ce qu'il ya un
coupable
finalement dans cette élimination mais
maintenant je sais que l'entraîneur ne
sait pas même si je n'ai pas le même
sujet par un coup pas coupable je sais
pas vous mais vous demander de soutenir
si on fait parler de platine à la fois
peut-être plus tard par nos missions qui
est ce qu'il ya un coupable sur sur
cette élimination des grands sages
encore l'entraîneur des plaisirs et
enfin gérer pour cent restants pas tous
en même temps y'a pas de coupable j'ai
regardé les hôtels du match enfin les le
score du match on voit bien que ça a été
deux matches très serrés
donc voilà ça joue un détail y'a pas de
coupable juste juste conduire
effectivement on perd le match quand
même sur un contre dans nos 22 mètres on
est contré sur un coup de pied de
dégagement
un essai transformé 7 points donc faire
le match là dessus et au match aller on
rate une pénalité à 20 mètres face aux
poteaux
mais après encore une fois on tenir pas
à pas démérité et a surtout c'est une
belle équipe et je souhaite bon courage
juste une petite chose je fais partie
des entraîneurs c'est pas un responsable
qui a c'est l'ensemble du groupe et
responsable
et quand je dis l'ensemble je m'y
associe ainsi que frédéric jardin qui
traîne avec moi et moi c'est ce que je
dis toujours aux joueurs c'est pas une
telle ou telle où les joueurs ou les
entraîneurs c'est le groupe c le groupe
et ses quelque part aussi le club
voilà donc il faut justement il faut
toutes ces défaites 7 cette défaite là
nous servent pour la saison prochaine et
ne pas refaire ce peut-être les mêmes
erreurs et on
on a commencé à y travailler j'ai une
question aussi avant de venir c'est
l'objectif du club en début de saison
c'était quoi c'est à la remontée en
fédérale 2 c'était la remontée un look
cher donc qui a donc vous êtes déçu yes
we tout allez vous aviez l'effectif pour
aller en fédérale 2 mais force est
forcément puisque on perd de ses
moindres détails
on perd ce match de play-offs et et on
est le prochain ces deux matches les
deux matches aller-retour pour la montée
d'eau quand on s'approche de très près
j'aurais bien sûr aimé aller aller
rivaliser avec auxerre et on ne s'est
pas donné les moyens mais on est très
proches donc on avait les moyens tout à
fait rugbystiquement on avait les moyens
après cette page rugby on passe au
handball et ça ne va pas très bien pour
les féminines de mon team otages
montigny-le-bretonneux va descendre en
nationale 2 les joueurs coachés par
bruno philippe se sont lourdement
inclinés à domicile contre saint
grégoire à rennes métropole le score 39
à 18 pour les bretonnes au classement
montigny toujours derniers du classement
avec un bilan de 3 victoires 1 nuls et
16 défaites depuis le début de la saison
quelles sont vos réactions par rapport à
cette élimination
quelles sont vos réactions avant de
passer au débat logique c'est logique
pour william bell sont pas au niveau
depuis le début de la saison voilà trois
victoires tartine de tartines de
défaites et quand je disais trois
victoires un nul et 16 des voix là donc
à un moment où là on peut pas combattre
face à la fatalité un peu d'en faire son
veut clairement à l'opposé de ce que
nous faisons parler tout avant de rugby
là pour le coes pour le coup c'est le
championnat qui a parlé 16 défaites
la messe est dite si je peux me
permettre ce genre pour moi je n'étais
pas là n'étaient pas à la hauteur de
cette division tout simplement donc des
fois il faut il faut savoir c'est
pouvoir
je veux savoir ce qui c'était la
première fois depuis dix ans a atteint
ce niveau là donc
ben voilà donc faut se servir de cette
expérience et puis pour ne par commettre
les mêmes erreurs mais approché
quelquefois faire faire la remontée faut
pas faux pas va falloir faire table
table rase de cette de cette saison veut
dire ben c'est raté
et puis quelques vols un club pour
quelquefois pour un club sportif de
sports collectifs il vaut mieux des fois
être être gras et chez les petits que
petit chez les grands parce que
l'accumulation des défaites fait que bay
spir l'ambiance y est plus et c'est la
spirale et est souvent une division en
moins 4 2 joue le haut de tableau
bell le climat n'est pas le même des
clubs voilà vous faites une belle
transition genre parce que vaut-il mieux
être une infirme de bas de classement en
national est une où une équipe du haut
du classement en nationale 2 nouveauté
cette puce partant pour l'éducation
versé pour le vélo bas du classement et
rouge c'est pour le haut du classement
devant une division en dessous
attendez on est on est cesser car
relativement simple on est sur du sport
amateur
on est d'accord c'est pas les proches ou
mais je vous mets roger la page hummer
défi contre rencontreront georges allez
je commence premier duel allait lui à
l'accord elles ont déjà deux contre deux
j'étais cola question d'accords petit
chez les grands grand chef d'audi oui
oui oui oui je dirais qu effectivement
être plusieurs saisons plusieurs années
en bas du classement se battre avec la
peur de descendre est toujours pénible
les 16 défaites j'imagine que le moral
des troupes était pas terrible donc il
vaut mieux effectivement descendre pour
repartir quand on reconstruire parce que
le moral de ses joueuses l'année en
prend un coup si on veut renouveler son
effectif et garder ses meilleurs
éléments vaut mieux repartir
peut-être personnel autant payer on l'a
fait à plusieurs reprises va peut-être
leur faire cette année donc bien sûr pas
redescendre un petit coup de fouet
essart parle d'après et puis voilà par
contre il faut pas la spirale des
défaites et c est ce qu on trouvait en
4e division et nas et c'est très très
dur mais redescend d'une division pour
se refaire la cerise bien sûr bien sûr
toujours un petit peu je trouvais moi je
pense qu'on parle de sport amateur
ils ne sont pas là on est passé pas ils
sont pas payés pour ça donc il faut que
le sport reste un plaisir avant tout et
quand on va sur les terrains quand on va
retrouver les copines ou les copains le
week-end et que ben on sait qu'on va
prendre une rouste on prend plus de
plaisir donc
donc pour moi en effet il vaut mieux
être dans une division inférieure et
être là pour soi viser la montée soit
être dans les dents dans la tête du
classement plutôt que de plutôt que se
prendre des roustes des rouges tous les
week-ends tout simplement sachant que
montigny finissez régulièrement 4 5e 6e
voire troisième du classement à chaque
fois depuis dix ans en national bien que
générationnel jeu mais sûrement un des
flics génération devant nous la fatalité
on pouvait trancher pour sa part est
carrément on est d'accord on est
d'accord il vaut mieux être petit chez
les grands il vaut mieux et il vaut
mieux dans la khl en voilà je
préférerais ne pas descendre et me
maintenir en division supérieure qui
taille dans le peloton de queue de
peloton pardon pour une raison simple
c'est que c'est vrai que ça reste un
plaisir on ne dira jamais assez mais
c'est aussi de la compétition et la
compétition moi je préfère jouer
toujours avec des adversaires de
meilleurs niveaux de meilleure facture
que l' inverse
on a entendu tout à leur plaisir dire
finalement on a joué qui avec des gens
qui étaient moins moins fort et on s'est
rendu compte que finalement on n'avait
pas suffisamment d'entraînement j'ai
même parlé du psg au plus haut niveau
donc je préfèrerais jouer - ya plus de
dresser au péage il ya plus de plaisir
peut-être également un bon n'oublions
jamais que quand on fait un match contre
un adversaire cet adversaire à une
quasiment une obligation et une
obligation réciproque
c'est de me donner mon niveau donc quand
je vais jouer avec quelqu'un qui est
meilleur que moi je sais où j'en suis si
je suis le premier d'une poule inférieur
finalement tous ceux qui sont derrière
moi viens juste m'expliquer parce que je
suis meilleur c'est parfait qui
m'interrogeait va parler je vais finir
ce qui m'intéresse moi c'est de toujours
m'améliorer et donc je préfère jouer
avec moi pour le dessus avec des gens
qui vont me demander de une exigence
supplémentaire parce que ça fait partie
de la formation c'est très pédagogique
que de continuer à apprendre
si c'est pour tout le temps gagner mes
matches bon d'accord les i non c'est pas
une question de temps gagné ce que d'une
question de temps à gagner mais là je
pense que toi tu réagis en tant qu' en
tant que footballeur et au foot
parmi elles six ici parce que là la
moins longue balle longue balle est un
sport qu'avec est assez proche par
exemple du bureau il ya des contacts il
ya quand même du contact je peux
t'assurer que les filles en prenant tous
les dimanches 20 points dans la gamelle
minimum et et
des filles qui soit peut-être deux fois
plus vite deux fois plus gaillards ne
faut plus et je peux te dire que le
moralement c'est peut-être n pas du
plaisir
tu peux pas prendre du plaisir c'est pas
possible sauf que marouane ses idées en
général donc j'ai pas entendu que
c'était mais en règle générale est sèche
et besoin d'un adversaire
la scène s'est passée c'était du
handball et handball je pense pas
qu'elle ait plus de plaisir apprendre à
apprendre des rouges de tous les livres
mais si les recettes tout en août voilà
ici et vous leur conseiller du coup gens
de rester en nationale 2 quelques années
encore d'euros contre green et qui va
descendre ensuite avant de remonter dès
l'année prochaine
mais le kilo mais ne s'en servir de se
servir justement de 7,2 de cette
expérience
cette dure expérience peut être pourra
dire qu est ce qui nous a manqué quel
poste il nous a manqué pour vraiment
sondés sont moment rester là qu'est-ce
qui est ce que vraiment on est on a trop
de joueuses et qui sont pas au niveau
est ce qui nous a manqué juste 2 3 il ya
certainement le côté technique des
entraîneurs de ce club qui fait qu' ils
peuvent savoir si ils peuvent vraiment
intérêt à chercher de trois joueuses
semaine de venir ou pas ça n'a pas de
sens pour sa descendance et marchent
toujours compliqué psychologiquement
pour remonter mais qui vaut mieux rester
dans sa catégorie
quitte à être coupé l on parle soir à
l'école je parle en général nous fallait
lancer dans le sport vaut mieux être
petit chez les grands ou grand chez les
petits je veux bien parler général
bateau s'il faut qu'on s'arrête que sur
le monde
je suis pas qualité pour marié roda il
faut pas oublier que pendant plusieurs
années il était autour de l'a34
cinquième place
quelle est la question en nationale 2
elle de nombreuses dans la question là
c'est en général la salle général à
l'aller par contre on se réfère
forcément dans le rapport alors qu'en
général je continue à penser la même
chose en particulier pour le monde j'ai
pas qualifié mais je suis d'accord à
chasser d'accord que la spirale négative
ah oui et à vaincre sans péril on
triomphe sans gloire
ça sera le mot de la fin pour yann donc
à c'est après cette page coup de
projecteur on passe maintenant à la
chronique j'aime j'aime pas de basile
regoli notre chroniqueur à basile rigoni
nous présente ces tops et les flops du
week-end à chaque émission alors
aujourd'hui base il n'est pas présent
sur ce plateau il est puni il a donné
trop de mauvais pronostic sur les
dernières émissions il devient prendre
exemple sur vous par exemple genre miss
qui avaient un parcours quasiment sans
faute sur les dernières émissions
voilà on écoute son premier âge aiment
ils concernent le volley ball
j'aime la belle saison de l'équipe de
masques l'équipe masculine de volley de
plaisir villepreux
les plaisirs oies et évolue en
prénationale et ont pour objectif de
remonter au niveau national en nationale
3 là où il jouait il ya quatre ans ils
ont terminé à la première place de leur
phase régulière
ils viennent d'entamer le week-end
dernier les play-offs qui sont plutôt
bien passées avec une victoire 3-0
contre anthony donc les voici qualifiés
pour la deuxième phase des play off qui
rassemblera trois autres équipes de
province cette fois au mois de mai il
faudra terminer pour les plaisirs oit
dans les deux premiers pour valider ce
ticket
en nationale 3 mustapha non j'étais trop
regarder l'état de la pelouse
parce que je suis au courant les rays
ont beau monde avait récemment boruc
pour le bien de terminer pour accueillir
lensois l'irlande pendant leur pour la
coupe d'europe
sachant qu'il ya pas grand-chose en foot
cette semaine faut que j'en place un
maximum donc la pelouse web bien sûr
bien sûr on est d'accord avec ça bien
sûr qu'on aime on adore donc aimé qu'ils
y arrivent à remonter après tant
d'années de galère
moustapha on en parlait de descendre de
monter deux voleurs
donc on est on est bien là ça prouve
bien que remonté c'est toujours une
galère quand on peut il rester on y
reste c'est juste pour finir sur mon
argument de tout à l'heure et laval a
valeureusement vaillamment insu si le
résultat du classement plaisir 37 6 6 0
est ce que vous pensez qu'ils se sont
régalés là cette saison je suis si on va
pas on va parler de choléra parle pas
souvent genre c'est une bonne chose
d'accord c'est une bonne chose de monter
de monthermé toujours marc de descendre
vers est temps d'aller de galles
attendue des cendres après tant d'années
de galère pour ce club
bah on va dire c'est l'aboutissement
d'un projet qu'ils ont un certain moment
était prévu depuis de longues années
puisque c'est et c'est tant mieux pour
eux et je leur souhaite impulser plaisir
donc
je leur souhaite une belle réussite et
la saison prochaine en nationale 3
ça montre que la ville de plaisir et est
très sportive on va passer au 16e j'aime
du coup de poing de facile les colis on
va passer en deuxième
il concerne le football et la jeune
génération du psg on écoute basile
j'aime la jeune génération de
footballeurs qui est actuellement au
paris saint germain et dont laurent
blanc l'entraîneur de l'équipe première
en ligue 1 semble faire confiance sur
ces derniers matchs de la saison
c'est une belle génération de jeunes
pétris de talent qui s'est notamment
illustré cette année en youth league la
ligue des champions pour les moins de 19
ans ils ont disputé la semaine dernière
la finale contre chelsea qu'ils ont
perdu certes 2 1 mais on a découvert
vraiment un certain nombre de pépites
dans cette formation parisienne
je pense notamment à des jeunes comme
nkou de coups jean kévin augustin
georgen m'a été beaucoup de jeunes qui y
auront je pense une chance au paris
saint germain la saison prochaine à eux
de la saisir
mais voilà je pense qu'il ya ya une
option à apprendre par les dirigeants et
un qatari qui va peut-être être de
compte est de plus en plus sûre sur la
formation parce que on voit qu'il ya des
ya des jeunes talentueux et qui auront
certainement leur place dans l'avenir
dans ce sens club de la capitale vous
êtes d'accord avec basile faut-il faire
confiance aux joueurs du psg aux jeunes
joueurs du psg plutôt qu'aux stars vous
êtes d'accord oui ou non
où voter oui non voilà j'en vis des
produits inand foot vous êtes indécis
nono il ya les deux versions qui sont
des versions bon un petit dieu lameca
avec mustapha comme un petit doigt elle
est allée georges commencé à les jeunes
cgj outre foot david amaury soccer
contre football à la jirs et au pg
brisant sur personne d'entraînement ils
ont une agglomération terrible pour
dénicher toutes les pépites est possible
et nécessaire mais voilà ils ont des
matches à enjeu d la chanteuse dee qui
fait que c'est très très difficile par
laurent blanc pour n'importe qui après
d'intégrer ces jeunes soient les prêter
qu'on aurait à la règle en arriver là
soit les vendre comme fallait vendre
dans les comm commun et c'est bien sûr
qu'ils ont les pépites mais alors
intégrer ça dans un champ que je sais
pas c'est difficile pour un club comme
le paris saint-germain d'intégrer des
jeunes je pense c'est plus facile pour
un plat de ne pas dire souvent phares
qui sont en élite
c'est déjà bien mais patiemment oui ils
ont besoin de vedettes ils ont besoin de
cadres ils ont besoin de mecs qui ont
fait ça sans match de coupe d'europe
c'est difficile on l'a vu hier on a vu
hier le triste match que ça donne et
n'avait que deux il essayait de balancer
deux petits jeunes n coucou et j'espère
qu'ils voilà quoi c'est difficile 1
c'est encore une fois on est on est sur
les principes parce que ça reste
compliqué à faire alors effectivement si
le psg c'est que du spectacle et par
définition on doit y mettre des vedettes
parce qu'on doit remplir les stades et
on doit faire venir du monde la vente de
ma graisse face à ça parce que derrière
il ya un gros business
face à ça on n'a rien à dire en train de
s'épuiser si on on est d'accord sauf que
si on parle foot par définition
l'intégration et la liane par l'état
lors du football amateur et du plaisir
qu'on doit avoir la même façon c'est à
la fois éducative c'est structurant il
ya des principes dans le football qui
valent dans la vie donc il ya tout ce
qu'il faut pour que ce soit justement la
jeune génération qui soit le plus de
plus en plus intégré mais en même temps
en même temps même les équipes pour le
coup les équipes spectacle ou celles qui
ont besoin de résultats pour faire
entrer pour faire rentrer
en termes d'économie faire rentrer de
l'argent ont de toute façon besoin de ce
genre là parce qu'à un moment de très
cher d'aller chercher les autres et
souvent les pépites
on les a et on va aller chercher aussi
par ailleurs donc c'est de toute façon
un plus pour un club que d'avoir des u19
et c'est vrai pour tous les clubs que ce
soit les amateurs que les professionnels
d'avoir des u19 qui sont au sommet
puisque l'on parle des u19 c'est c'est
la gambardella européenne en servir ils
sont très très très fort et en
l'occurrence ils n'ont pas démérité
devant chelsea
donc oui on est d'accord face au
spectacle en donnait il ya des stars
voilée watch et les auditions parfois il
ya vingt-deux international food ya
beaucoup de jeunes de jeunes qu'on a
même vu ronaldo je me souviens d'ornano
l'avoir vu il avait quoi 17 ans quand il
jouait encore en équipe nationale
j'aurais signé entre
il aurait pu à ce moment là juste
d'arriver je cherchais du monde mais
c'est pour dire que c'est un pari qu'on
fait quand même sur l'avenir et quand on
est dirigeant
on doit s'adosser sur les jeunes on doit
s'adosser sur l'avenir sinon c'est
mourant alors ce genre alors qui a
raison
il devait trancher jean paul giroud ce
merci mustapha hammouche la fin merci
rien mustapha non mais c'est vrai c'est
vrai que tous les clubs pros de football
ont besoin d'une école de rugby de
l'ordre aussi ça me donne l école de
football
oden écoles et moi je passe ils vont
peut-être sortir un joueur seul sur sur
tout l'ensemble c'est qu'il sera capable
d'évoluer en équipe première mais c'est
fait pour ça et ça n'avait pas le niveau
de cette équipe de jeunes soko et si on
parlait de gens qui ont une existence
pendant la pause ben oui mais j'y vais à
psg lorient où il a joué et
c'était vraiment vraiment très compliqué
pour lui et dans le quinze matchs il a
marqué un but et c'était là et c'était
lorient face donc voilà est-ce que
est-ce qu'ils sont complètement effacée
par par ces stars qui à côté de qui joue
ou est ce que il ya trop de pression
quand ils sont partis quand ils
possèdent le ballon mais c'est vrai que
j'avais avec plaisir de la peine pour
lui mais c'est vrai que je me disais
mais comment est-ce qu'il va pouvoir
réussir à trouver sa place au milieu de
tout ça c'est la position il faut la
répéter
on est d'accord mais bon déjà déjà
quinze matches déjà cuit il a joué 15
matchs sur la saison en ligue 1 moi je
pense que sur une saison de ligue 1
justement ils ont des élastiques match
en coupe mais ils ont dit qu'ils ont des
équipes que le psg va rencontrer sur
lequel qui peuvent faire entrer ces
jeunes joueurs soient et oui on va peut
être faire plus jouer justement les
jeunes le battre ce record est tous les
records de convois par exemple la virée
à las vegas il faut je ne serai pas
faire jouer je préfère jouer fort de les
faire jouer clairement mais ce que mon
collègue il a tout à fait raison donc
pour un matin il a tout à fait raison
nos clubs ne tiennent que grâce aux
jeunes là par exemple la saison nos
juniors surfe éliminé à montpellier la
semaine dernière
là on va jouer à kelly tâtonnant domaine
5 voilà on va leur donner un petit peu
le goût de cette vision relative cette
division là on est dans un sport
spectacle j'adore j'adore le le psg le
psg si composent s'il fait la moitié de
l'équipe avec celle que ces gamins 19
ans qui joue sûrement très très bien
c'est tant mieux spectacle les maillots
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent acheter le
maillot d'augustin kouadio la deuxième
chose c'est que l'objectif c'est de
gagner la ligue des champions
le championnat est strictement rien à
faire ils pourraient finir 5e du
championnat l'année prochaine s'ils
gagnent la ligue des champions c'est là
bas ils ont réussi leur saison donc
gardien mais une vraie volonté quand
même de la part du psg quand même
d'inclure les joueurs les joueurs par
exemple le 27 avril il ya eu edson
oddsson edwards qui a 19 ans quel si son
contrat pro on est vraiment dans une
logique vraiment de lyon s'insinuer de
contenu et un projet finalement qui a
été lancé depuis l'arrivée des qataris
et en 5 jeudi c'est comme toute
entreprise il y à un modèle qui en place
des greniers dans les moyens simplement
se pérenniser et ça passe de toute façon
parce pas parler son culot d'aller
chercher et chercher comme tout en avril
à doha 80 70 millions d'euros comme j'ai
entendu par les enseignants dans
millions 73 voilà comme je viens de lui
parler dernièrement et d'ainsi la pépite
qui peuvent la forme et je pense qu'ils
en seront quand même aussi très
satisfait pour la revente très cher
voilà pour la rentrée cher mais un vrai
mâle et la pépite même un mec comme
ronaldo il n'a pas commencé au bénin qui
concerne j'espère il a commencé au sport
tu n'aimes pas enfin à madère mènerait
au sporting il était déjà qu'il va nous
falloir laisser leur chance dans un très
grand voilà difficile définition ils ont
tous aussi gamme un mois de la fin c'est
le mois de la fin ils sont repassés
maintenant on dernier j'aime pas de base
il a rigolé il a été curé
j'aime pas la deuxième partie de saison
catastrophique de l'équipe féminine de
football 2
l'aes mancini alors que les inimités n
était
classé dans la première partie de
tableau au moment de la trêve hivernale
et
elles sont contraints d'enchaîner
enchaîné les défaites elles restent
malheureusement sur une série de six
revers consécutifs qui les ont fait
glisser dans les profondeurs du
classement et surtout dans cette zone de
relégation qui risque de les envoyer
peut-être l'an prochain en dhr
il reste une seule journée aura lieu
dans une semaine
un match à étendre qu'il faudra
impérativement gagner pour pour se
maintenir
c'est triste de voir cette équipe de
montigny jouer son maintien en dh et se
dire qu'il ya encore il ya encore deux
ans elle s'était en d2 et il ya même
quatre ou cinq ans elles ont fait lé
évoluer en première division
comment un club qui évolué en d1 en
2009-2010 peut descendre en dessert
l'équivalent de la quatrième division
la spirale négative à ce qui est dit de
tout à l'heure
donc on la sent virale négative a
descendu une fois eh ben c'est pas
toujours évident de pouvoir retaper et
de dire on va enfin quoi en faire déjà
maintenue
souvent ces exemples dans laquelle vaut
mieux rester petit chez petit chez les
grands je pense qu'on sera d'accord avec
rigoler effectivement il a maintenant ça
commence à il passe en dhr en dhr alors
à mon avis a peut-être il ya peut-être
une explication à mon avis vaut
peut-être plus rationnelle que celle là
sérieuse ça c'est pour probablement pas
simplement jouer au club de montigny
merci mais également ceux peut-être sur
50 ans ni viennent également avec la
création votre club alors je veux le
féminin vous leur avez mené certaines
heureuse c'est là où je voulais en venir
effectivement on n'a pas créé une
section féminine pour leur faire du tort
pour faire de la compétition à qui que
ce soit c'est juste que ça s'impose
d'avoir des filles qui jouent au foot
dans tous les clubs
cela étant c'est vrai qu'elle était elle
était seule on va dire ça l'eau sale au
pays 1 et que depuis il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont partis il ya beaucoup de
clubs qui sont en train de se mettre au
féminin donc lorsqu'on est à peu près
seul en compétition on a un peu tendance
à glorifier un peu son travail et la
remise en question n'est peut-être pas
forcément là c'est en ça que j'ai tout à
l'heure c'est important que des jeunes
soient promulguées qui est encore une
fois que ça vienne de la base est là
j'ai le sentiment mais c'est qu'un
sentiment que montigny seul au village
seul au pays seulement à la casse qui
pour le coup
à peut-être surestimé et se voir il
faudrait passer à voir un seul club à
saint quentin en yvelines avec les
meilleures joueuses mais mes 50 ans moi
ça a été ma volonté depuis que je suis
arrivé au club de foot aussi bien pour
les garçons que pour les filles
à force de saupoudrer des subventions
sur plusieurs clubs et tous rester
finalement bas de tableau parce que le
plus haut niveau ces trappes en ph
on peut quand même faire mieux sur le
saint quentinois ces temples et des
locaux qui sont quand même en élite
je parle je parle de foot pardon mais
non mais c'est pour dire que plutôt que
de saupoudrer effectivement sur
plusieurs communes on pourrait avoir une
équipe saint quentinois vrai pour les
filles vrai pour les garçons cela étant
ce n'est pas aussi simple que ça parce
que je vais pour le coup je les
pratiquer mais pour revenir aux filles
elles sont descendues donc en dh et la
maintenant en dhr je pense qu'il ya
quelque chose de cet ordre là c'est à
dire on n'a de toute façon le club seul
club au féminin et je pense qu'il ya
peut-être ça je sais pas je rien gros
problèmes en défense
tu étais à perdre le vôtre en perdons
asia les ira le mieux la fin alesi
georges et qu'ils ont le sport un matin
on retrouve ce genre de club dans
n'importe quel sport qui à un moment
donné on a vu le
le volet avant pendant 10 ans on voit le
trou il ya un effet de génération 7
fédérations sur le prévoir quelques
années en avance voilà vous avez fille
qui fatigue vous qu'on sait que des
gamins de 18 20 ans après à 24,50 sûr
pas par exemple boulot j'étais à ce
terrain si vous préférez pâle avance
l'équipe
rome suscité un rom et l'on oublie qu on
continue à présent cette émission par
notre rubrique débats
la troisième étape de la coupe du monde
de bmx était programmée le 8 le week-end
du 8 mai aux pays-bas cette occasion à
manon à valentino a brillé avec une
troisième place et jérémy rencurel à lui
terminé 13e
les deux pilotes sont des prétendants
sérieux pour partir aux jo de rio à
l'été prochain
cette troisième place devrait probable
probablement propulser la verrie airoise
manon valentino jeu nous l'avons
rencontrée sur la piste du bmx de saint
quentin en une fois j'essaie un peu de
relativiser ou me dire qui je prends le
risque d'être énormément déçu parce que
c'est du bmx et tout peut arriver là
chut on peut être premier tombé tout
seul ça mais en même temps je me vois
mal si je suis qualifié pour aller aux
jeux y aller juste pour faire acte de
présence et non moi j'y vais pour une
médaille par là je vous le rappelle le
bmx et sport olympique depuis 2008 et
pékin ce sport méritent ils d'être
olympique
vous votez oui ou non pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas vous êtes tous d'accord
allez-y lors des guerres chaudes
premiers acheteurs de ces extrêmes cette
insolence tiers rapportent des médailles
à la france
le rappelle que caroline chausson qui
était bien quitter vététistes et passer
au bmx pour les jeux olympiques est allé
remporter le premier titre des jeux
olympiques donc et je pense que les
éditions suivantes c'est aussi des
français qui étaient sur le sur le
podium donc c'est un sport qui
rapportent des médailles la france donc
il est hors de question de l'enlever du
programme olympique
faut pas recevoir de toujours toujours
chaud et et ensuite c'est quand même un
sport qui est hyper spectaculaire
j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir aller voir
les championnats de france de bmx à
massy l'année dernière et
et vraiment c'était c'était super vous
avez
mon ami bravo mon ami ouais c'était
vraiment top vous avez vous avez une
manche qui à peine sorti de là de la du
parcours que déjà une nouvelle manche
commence donc c'est un spectacle
non-stop
et puis il envoie quand même
furieusement il ya beaucoup de rythme il
envoie quand même bien bien j'ai eu la
chance de faire aussi une initiation sur
la piste de bmx et quand vous arrivez à
la fin de la d'initiation d'une heure
vous les sentez vos bras donc quand il
enchaîne comme ça plusieurs manches
c'est vraiment un très très beau sport
et et voilà pour le spectacle moi je moi
j'aime beaucoup
donc oui complètement normal que ce soit
pour dames olympique georges vous êtes
d'accord avec anne oui tous les sports
devrait être au programme olympique
d'ailleurs mais c'est sélectionné quand
une moto cross sont sans moteur quoique
maintenant on retrouve a pas de moteur
partout dans mon vélo mais on vous
règlerez sa mort j'ai encore pas mais
c'est sûrement un très beau sport ce
comme aux beaux pas semblé sao des
centres de ski laquelle ils font
maintenant on l'a dans les jeunes de jeu
dans l'arctique ski 3 c'est tout oui
c'est un sport un peu particulier mais
pourquoi pas les mecs ils sont très
sûrement on n'est pas champion du monde
de france de navarre sacré entraîneur
mais les jeux olympiques devrait être
d'abord très large il faut faire des
sports grappiller des jeux olympiques
sur un an fait pour vous non mais
plusieurs ya l'hiver il est et pourquoi
pas l'automne et pourtant quoi les jeux
d'autres nous ont toujours juste le et
le démarreur de l'équipe de nouvelle
zélande sur piste pour revenir un peu à
la piste c'est un ancien
gars du bmx c'est à dire qu'ils ont un
talent et ils sont allés chercher un
gars qui avait des qualités
d'explosivité dans cette discipline et
ils l'ont mis sûr allusion
il ya des vraies qualités physiques et
ils l'ont mis sur la piste et
aujourd'hui c'est l'éthique qui est
championne du monde a voté pour non oui
bien sûr moi est absolument la seule
réflexion c'est que je viens cette
émission depuis quelques temps on
invente des sports en permanence alors
le décret dans les régions arides en
juin aux états unis jean mora fait vous
appelez dernière fois sur un comme un
essor aux états unis de mon ami non je
parle pas de celui-ci je parle en
général
en général il ya beaucoup de sport qui
sont maintenant inventer on les découvre
à cette émission et je remercie encore
une fois tv film parce que vraiment on
en apprend tous les jours
canal un cap a été inventé c'est
probablement le foot avec des bosses
parce que c'est l'espoir que j'ai pas vu
paul signac ça que ça m'inspire où le
rugby je sais pas peut-être qu'avec des
boss y aurait peut-être des fois les
terreurs il serait peu 25 des licenciés
dans l'hexagone 4 millions de
pratiquants dans le monde finalement ça
sert à devenir un sport olympique
avoir autant de pratiquants forcément
forcément ici pas de représentations
dans le monde
c'est ce seul ce soir voilà c'est un
sport qui sont voués à mourir de même
mais là c'est pas le cas puis en plus là
je rejoins jan pour une fois la mérite
c'est tellement rangement le rugby
pourquoi le rugby n'est pas aux jeux
olympiques ça c'est assez sombre associe
non mais c'est vrai que mes amis même
temps le vrai rugby
non non non non non mais le pressent de
revenir au bmx pour revenir au bmx quand
même c'est quand même des athlètes à
part entière canton - bull à la pêche
qu'ils ont mises aux arrêts cardio
énorme puis des cuisses et vous jours on
passe maintenant notre deuxième débat il
s'appelle nicolas zens il a 19 ans il
est originaire de conflans sainte
honorine il mesure 1 mètre 95 et ils
postulent évolue au poste de
réceptionneur attaquant et surtout
l'illinois est devenu le week-end du 8
mai un champion universitaire avec un
oeil à ohio state à il est donc devenu
le deuxième meilleur français à réussir
cette performance avec kevin tilly en
2012 et 2013 en lait coûte le plus c'est
que kirin kiki la paix avant qu'il y
joue avec les pros et il est dans
l'équipe olympique donc tu as un motif
poursuivre le travail commence à payer
quoi je vais pas dire que je ma patrie
qui veut prendre parce qu'ils ont des
joueurs qui sont bien au dessus de moi
pour l'informer je pense que c'est déjà
un bon pas et voilà quoi je présenterai
niveau des coachs et niveau qu
sélectionneur
cette performance est l'une des plus
belles peut-être dans l'histoire du
volley français
et pourtant on en parle très peu dans
les médias est ce que ça vous choque
oui ou non voter ça me choque est ce que
ça vous choque
george george contre yann aller il ya le
cancer je commence non ça ne veut pas
d'une première chose on parle cadre du
volet bull
il faut que champion universitaire wii
est un des juges il n'y a rien de
favorable de volley ball pour voir des
matchs de l'équipe de france sur france
télévisions il faut qu'ils gagnent ils
soient en finale du tournoi pré
olympique ou qu'ils aient déjà fait un
exploit formidable alors que le volley
ball s'est juste alors que lui
volley ball c'est comme un sport
vraiment magnifique et un sport où
pareil cas il ya de très très beau très
beau échanger de très belles phases de
jeu à voir et là en plus on parle de
sport universitaire aux états unis donc
pourquoi est ce que nous on vend
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne va en parler en
france voilà on a rien à faire et
aujourd'hui la le peu de visibilité que
le volley-ball à c'est grâce à l'équipe
de c'est grâce à l'équipe de france
la timide avoue qu'il nous fait qu'elle
nous fait quand même un super un super
job qui va sûrement se qualifier poison
là on espère qu'ils vont se qualifier
pour les olympiques et qui vont nous
ramener une belle médaille des jo parce
que ce qu'ils ont fait l'année dernière
c'est quand même juste énorme
donc voilà non c'est normal qu'on ne
parle pas d'un joueur qu'ils soient
français qui soit aux états unis et qui
gagne voilà même city même si tu y étais
aussi est aussi un très bon un très
grand joueur un très grand joueur de
volley mais non ça ne choque absolument
pas à vos jambes
ben moi ça me choque parce que ce genre
d'espoir koné nous aussi dans le
football américain
on va peut-être avoir notre premier
joueurs formés en france qui va intégrer
la nfl c'est en cours actuellement là il
était déjà écouté et s'est donc ces gars
là qu'ils sortent un peu de l'ordinaire
dans n'importe quel sport
c'est un gars du lieu image a eu des
gars du rugby sont partout nouvelle
zélande et tout mais s'il ya des gars
qui sortent dans un pays comme ça ben
voilà ça ça permet de faire de faire un
petit peu de lumière juste pour là je
pense que le volet on avait besoin le
football mais à qui on a besoin et pour
savoir qu' il ya des portes les états
unis s'est pas ouvert à tout le monde
même si c'est ce que les gens avaient un
universitaire et c'est très drôle
arrivée bébé sur ces deux là qui passent
pros et qui alimente tous les tous les
grands clubs d'europe
c'est dans ce niveau donc oui oui un
petit article dans l'équipe je pense
qu'il a eu au moins je sais pas ce qu'il
a eu comme pour moi tu as eu l'info
c'est vrai lui c'est pour ça qu'on va
tous passer un petit peu de lumière tout
en temps à n'importe quel sport mémo bmx
pourquoi pas et lesbiennes à vers votre
enseigne par exemple cette finale
ça me choque par exemple augmentent on
les bat on n'est pas retransmis
saint-pardon sur l'équipe 21 par exemple
non ça se passe pas en france voilà donc
pour moi non ça ne fait pas par contre
je suis très très content quand l'équipe
21 retransmet les matchs de l'équipe de
france et julien regarde quand l'équipe
à terre pas transmis les matchs de
l'équipe de france de volley-ball bien
sûr ça c'est ça pour moi c'est important
sur une jambe
je rejoins l'yonne je rejoignais et
c'est lui-même qui le dit le joueur
il n'a pas le niveau pour être en équipe
de france actuellement c'est lui même
qui l'a dit mme g 20 ans qui a dix nord
voilà non mais c'est pas une question
d'âge 1 4 tonne un niveau surtout volet
civil un niveau et il l'a pas il l'a dit
lui-même
donc là ça me choque absolument pas
qu'elle aille a montré une finale des
états unis universitaire de volley ball
il a quand même un france le sport comme
vous et moi j'veux pas forcément les
jeunes à ce lancement ce sport également
peut-être gens non sur une question
sport après je pense que voilà ça c'est
il ya comme un petit mot c'est que
l'universitaire aux états unis ça vous
paraît mois à pratiquement tous les
meilleurs sports tous les premières
divisions sofoot com comment les
académies de tennis mais qui vont sortir
de très très bon joueur de tennis des
états-unis moi ça me choque pas enfin ça
se passe le jour les mêmes aux
etats-unis le volet même aux états unis
risque de voir mes amis ne s'est pas
médiatique et c'est pour le basket par
exemple ce que j'attendais tout leur
gardien off on parle de nos avait pas de
lui mais c'est pas le basket quand même
50 basket la sq n'a pas volé non non
j'ai pas dit qu'ils étaient au niveau où
vous les états unis après ce débat on
passe maintenant au traditionnel défi du
jour
le défi concerne aujourd'hui le rugby
les joueurs de versailles se sont prêtés
au jeu
le but tapé le poteau en tirant au pied
et ils s'en sont plutôt bien sortis
regardez du quart monde voilà ça fait
dix ans que je suis à versailles au
rugby club
et voilà je vous sens troyer on va
essayer de relever le défi aujourd'hui
avec mes copains voilà c'est mon surnom
club
quelle torture masquelier je suis
talonneur à versailles ça fait à peu
près 8 novembre chez au club et mon
surnom c'est moskova aussi de relever le
défi sylvain charles un je suis est liée
au flop de versailles depuis quatre ans
au surnom c'est la charme et j'essaie de
relever le défi allez si la rose donc
fui à versailles depuis cette saison
mon surnom ses séquelles j'y vois là
je
c'est très sympa on à le bouter
tranquille avec les copains c'était cool
en plus j'ai gagné dans wana qui sont
très bons très très bon et d'acquis qui
sont moins bons elle donnera pas de moi
j'habite au que ces tests et kenji
favori mais il a craqué sous la pression
genre une réaction ouais c'est pas mal
ils n'ont pas touché beaucoup et non en
peu de temps finalement parce que le sky
rugby avait mis 45 minutes avant tout
chez le premier poteau une anomie
finalement dix minutes
donc ça va bien dévoué mustapha mustapha
me disait des diplomates on comprend
mieux pourquoi ils vont apprécier
message je pense on passe maintenant aux
coups de gueule d'arnaud le gouic
vous en avez désormais l'habitude notre
chroniqueur arnaud louis alias le grinch
yvelinois pousse un coup de gueule sur
le sport dans le département à chaque
émission aujourd'hui arnaud va nous
parler de l'euro 2016 et des fans zone
arnaud je vous laisse la parole merci
michael
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de
l'euro 2016 qui approche très très
rapidement la salle y en a plus que pour
quelques semaines
ça devrait être une très belle fête en
fait non c'est non c'est pas trop
puisque pour l'instant mais l'économie
ne communique pas vraiment sur ce
qu'elle compte organiser
est-ce qu'on va avoir une fan zone
yvelinoise est ce qu'on aura des écrans
géants un peu partout pour l'instant
c'est pas trop c'est dommage parce qu'on
a trois équipes dans les yvelines qui
sont installés on a la france savait
qu'avec clairefontaine on a aussi la
russie à croissy-sur-seine et l'irlande
à versailles donc un euro 2016 en france
20 il y en aura pas ça va pas se
reproduire a dit si d'ici peu de temps
une grosse compétition comme ça il faut
en profiter ça dommage d'être obligé
d'aller jusqu'aux champs de mars pour
faire la fête ensemble et ou alors j'ai
regardé ça dans son dans son salon tout
seul donc j'espère que les communes vont
faire quelque chose c'est mon avis vous
êtes d'accord à carnot il faut des fans
zone ici dans les yvelines où voter oui
non ok bon argent contre moustapha al et
pour terminer non gens vont commencer
ouais donc simplement sportivement oui
je le rejoins sportivement et il en
faudrait maintenant je sais que même sur
paris il n'aura qu'une seule c'est celle
au champ-de-mars en mars avec six ou
sept entrées seulement aient filtré
je crois qu on vit actuellement
ben un contexte particulier on est allé
en corse où l'état d'urgence il faut pas
il faut pas l'oublier
jusqu'à fin juillet n'ont pas trop
sérieux mais c'est la réalité des choses
et je crois que je crois que s'il n'y a
pas la multiplication de ces zones avec
écran géant
c'est justement pour éviter pour éviter
qu'ils aient qui est trop de protection
à faire uniquement oms à mon avis parce
que effectivement c'est une grande fête
l'euro et on n'est pas prêt de le revoir
mais forcément il ya quand même un
problème de responsabilité et de
sécurité sur plusieurs mois je pense que
plusieurs noms le problème de la
sécurité est évident simplement
l'emprunt de la sécurité il est là il
est récurrent on est dans un état
d'urgence
on l'était pas avant mais les problèmes
de sécurité en a toujours eu besoin et
on vit dans une société de plus en plus
violente
au delà de l'état de au delà de l'état
d'urgence dire que au delà du terrorisme
il ya de plus en plus de terreur sur les
territoires les plus en plus de violence
sauf que à un moment donné on doit
continuer à vivre on doit continuer le
sport on doit continuer à faire la fête
et un moment donné c'est à nous de
relever ce défi le défi de la sécurité
qui de toute façon un défi à relever
quelques siècles
mustapha retard dont vous êtes pour la
fête donc je suis pour après je
comprends que ce soit un obstacle
le problème de la sécurité sur un
obstacle c'est juste qu'il faut le
surmonter celui-là ça c'est le premier
point c'est vrai ils surmonter ces packs
deuxièmement excuses deuxième
deuxièmement deuxièmement ça a un coût
voilà que je peux comprendre aussi que
quand on voit les difficultés qu'on
rencontre par rapport aux subventions
dans les yvelines en subventions aux
sports et au sport amateur en
particulier peut-être qu'il ya un signe
qui est donné en disant on va pas non
plus donner un signe de festif et de
dépenses important je crois que c'est 24
27 millions d'euros dépensés cette année
dans les
d'abord j'aime pas ce mot fan zone on
peut dire que c'est des zones de
supporters d endroit de convivialité de
supporters appelons ça comme ça mais pas
forcément pas mais peut-être avec
modération avec madame assure jean donc
à la limite on a un ministre qui dit il
y en aura il ya 24 27 millions qui sont
débloqués pour donc si un ministre le
dit c'est qu'on veut donner un signe
fort sur le territoire dans ce cas là on
devrait pouvoir le faire partout ça
reste un handicap
il faut le relever après si c'est un
problème financier qu'on dise parce
qu'après tout moi j'ai pas l'argument
j'essaie d'expliquer mais j'ai pas
l'argument mais si on devait enfin si on
me pose la question de savoir s'il
fallait ou pas il faudra le faire
georges votre enchère y sera bien seul à
parler je change de sens effectivement
si on pouvait avoir ne serait-ce que 500
euros de plus par le département pour
fait très très peu pour le sport dans
les yvelines
je vote est ce que on va voir ce qui se
passe dans tous les autres départements
on n'est pas très favorisée dans les
yvelines les jeux et je le redis yann
très rapide regroupement justement ce
week-end par exemple il ya le
championnat de france de vitesse et
d'omnium qui a lieu au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
je participe samedi et dimanche donc je
viens juste très fier de moi il y aurait
grégory baugé il y aura michael
d'almeida
il va y avoir un peu de spectacle à
l'année dernière avec très peu de monde
dans les tribunes dont six des 50 ils ne
peuvent se déplacer cette année cette
satanée voix se seraient montrés bien
heureusement pour les moteurs
il aura pas de moteur ici c'est la fin
de cette émission merci à 26 mai pour un
nouveau numéro de six ans par les sports
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez regarder à
nouveau cette émission sur youtube et
sur notre site internet
à bientôt sur tv fil 78